I think I'm actually
like addicted to doing Hulk Hogan yeah I
do I think I can't well do you have Hulk
Hogan days
all Coke and days sorry honey today's
the Hulk Hogan day and you just [__]
our Hulk Hogan for 24 hours
I'll go good days that's that's Molly's
[__] like worst nightmare sorry honey
it's my birthday you know what that
means
well hold on a second dude here's the
way it works brother you uh you get
stoned dude because your podcast told
you too brother but then you you're
thinking ahead of the game you before
you even started recording you're
ordering a pizza dude and then it timed
perfectly and then it times perfectly
right with pizza the movie dude what was
that bizarre that's a good time to only
talk like Hulk Hogan brother